yo what is up everybody mad Luigi here
bringing some more fallout 4 content now
today and be showing you guys how to get
the righteous Authority which is a rare
unique laser rifle in fallout 4 so what
you're going to want to do is gonna
wanna head a little bit north west of
Boston and just in the general area just
wait till you pick up the military
frequency AF 95 which will prompt the
mission fire support you're going to
listen to this radio it's going to
further prompt the mission you're gonna
hear some people in distress and you're
going to go need to help them now this
is going to be at the Cambridge police
station which is a little closer to the
city then chances are you'll hear prom
maybe you'll hear from inside the city's
you got to go a little bit out though so
if you go to your quests you mark on
your map it will be pretty easy to see
you can probably pick up the signal
anywhere in the general area you just
have to listen to it so find the marker
just head straight to the marker most of
the missions and what you need to do is
fairly self-explanatory to get the rifle
from here since you're going to need
complete admission so once you get to
the Cambridge police station you're
going to see a guy in trouble just kill
all the ghouls he's fighting the googles
he's power armor his laser rifle that
laser rifle he's using is actually the
one that you're gonna get that is the
righteous Authority so kill all the
ghouls and once you kill all them you
can go in and talk to him and he's gonna
bring you inside to talk to them again
to start new mission this new mission is
going to be to help these guys out get a
long-range radio transmitter and it's
pretty self-explanatory because it
guides you through it gives you markers
and just follow him paladin Dan's he's
really strong so it shouldn't be too
hard of a mission two things I do want
to make note of in the mission i'm not
gonna show it all the spoilers in the
mission there's going to be a tesla
science magazine on a table just in a
room as soon as you walk in the room
it'll be pretty easy to see it's a room
that you have to go through to go on
through the missions just keep an eye
out for that helps with energy weapons
which you're going to be using and also
the very bottom floor is going to be the
junk jet which is another rare unique
item I believe it's rare unique so it's
a just a big contraption that lets you
shoot out junk so any of your junk any
of my junk you can just shoot louder
people that's pretty cool if you guys
want that it's right here at the bottom
I didn't take it but you saw me take it
by dropping cuz I'm too don't have
enough space after that just continue to
complete the mission follow paladin
Dan's outside talk to him he's gonna
thank you you give him what he wants
he's going to give you a righteous
authority as thanks and you can see it's
going to be it is a really powerful
weapon
obviously you can modify it to do more
it gives you a lot better critical
critical do double damage and the
critical meter feels fifteen percent
faster so hope you guys have enjoyed
this guy to be sure to check out my
channel since i will be posting a lot
more stuff like this and yeah thank you
for watching and follow for is hype step